jealousy over money social media shade
nerds collide oh my was there more
surface tension on the set of the big
bang theory than we first realized keep
watching for what you need to know about
kaley cuoco and mayam bialik's real
relationship
at its heart the big bang theory is a
show about friendship while it's true
that the series essentially follows a
group of socially awkward nerds
friendship is an important part of daily
lives of mega nerd sheldon cooper and
his like-minded companions among plenty
of other notable friendships the pairing
of penny played by kaylee cuoco and amy
played by mayambialic stands out as one
of the show's most prominent though the
two have quite a difficult time getting
to know one another after amy is first
introduced in season three by the end of
the series they're as thick as thieves
in spite of their many differences
however some online gossip has suggested
that the actors who play these two
characters might not be as chummy as
their on-screen counterparts in fact
rumors swirled for years regarding a
possible on-set feud between cuoco and
bialik some gossip websites have even
alleged that the stars were once
embroiled in a so-called cat fight and
that the two once had to be physically
separated from each other as is often
the case when it comes to celebrity
gossip there's apparently not much
credence to these claims in fact it's
fair to say that bialik and cuoco seem
to share a solid friendship in real life
as well as on screen
well obviously the cast we had great
chemistry from the beginning
while rumors of a feud between kaylee
cuoco and mayam bialik may be
entertaining and at least somewhat
plausible they're not entirely accurate
of course it's not unheard of for cast
members on a long-running series like
the big bang theory to develop some
animosity especially when large sums of
money are involved in fact money happens
to be the cause of the rumor in question
which reportedly emerged due to a
massive pay gap between the show's
original and later cast members more
specifically these rumors claim that
bialik made 100 thousand dollars an
episode while cuoco made one million
dollars which upset bialik however many
of the articles discussing these rumors
list no real sources to back up their
claims meanwhile evidence of cuoco and
bialik's real-life friendship seems much
more credible for example according to
variety cuoco and the other original big
bang theory co-stars took pay cuts in
2017 to increase the paychecks of both
bialik and melissa rausch who plays
bernadette on the show while cuoco and
the other original stars still made much
more money than their newer counterparts
their pay cuts were an important gesture
regardless of a potentially significant
pay gap between the two actors it seems
that they're friends in real life when
cuoco got married to her now ex-husband
carl cook in 2018 bialik was notably one
of the few big bang theory cast members
to actually attend the ceremony as a
result it seems apparent that the two
are closer than certain rumors may
suggest mayam bialik herself once
addressed the subject of her
relationship with kaylee cuoco first
hand during a video interview with wired
as part of a series in which
participants are asked some of the most
searched questions about themselves
bialik responded directly to whether or
not she and cuoco are friends
well we worked together for nine years
and i went to her wedding and celebrated
things with her i would say we're
friends
furthermore bialik and cuoco both
participated in a cast reunion in
glamour magazine to commemorate the book
the big bang theory the definitive
inside story of the epic hit series
while it certainly seems as though a
friendship between the two actors exists
it's also possible that vialic and cuoco
may not be as close as they have
publicly implied specifically one reddit
user pointed out that cuoco doesn't
follow bialik on instagram in spite of
the fact that bialik follows cuoco and
once tagged her in a photo
in short the rumored animosity between
bialik and cuoco seems to be overblown
nevertheless the instagram discrepancy
suggests that a certain degree of
tension could exist between the two
actors perhaps they're just two people
who don't necessarily see eye to eye but
work together on one of the most popular
tv shows of all time check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
tv show star's real life relationships
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]